[Música]
continuamos analizando los efectos de la
crisis climática en los alimentos
hablamos ahora el café que con el tiempo
se ha convertido en un alimento básico y
presente en millones de hogares de todo
el mundo lo tomamos en casas en las
oficinas las cafeterías restaurantes en
todo el planeta brasil es el mayor
productor y abastecedor mundial del café
exportando alrededor de 11 millones de
sacos de este grano en el primer
trimestre de este año el 21 más de un 10
por ciento que el mismo periodo del año
anterior el 20 seguido de vietnam
colombia y también indonesia sin embargo
hay una amenaza en el mundo cafetero y
el grano se puede convertir en una
víctima colateral de los efectos del
cambio climático para ello quiero dar la
bienvenida a juan a juan manuel cert en
ls barista empresario colombiano además
el barista de nada menos que tom cruise
gracias a juan por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo américa de francés
de 4 muy buen día muy buen día muchas
gracias a ustedes pues le quiero empezar
preguntando usted como cafetero que
creció en una finca cafetera con una
familia que trabaja en este en este
rubro no de qué manera
afecta al cambio climático al café como
lo sienten ustedes en industria pues la
verdad que es un tema bastante delicado
porque el café es bien temático en
cuanto al clima en las partes
específicas donde crece crece en lo que
llamamos la el cinturón del café que
viene siendo digamos todo lo que está
alrededor del ecuador el café no tolera
cambios drásticos de temperatura el café
no le gustan temperaturas muy altas ni
muy bajas parte del problema que estamos
teniendo este año fueron las heladas en
brasil en julio el cual creó un
desabastecimiento increíble para toda la
cadena de café eso nos hizo de verdad
primero el precio se incrementó de una
forma increíble en brasil produciendo
casi un tercio del café que se consume
en el mundo
y nos da una imagen casi a lo que vamos
a competir ahora que tenemos problemas
climáticos
-juan esto afecta pues directamente la
calidad del grano el café es cierto
claro que si el café el café tiene tiene
tiene que ser también cuidado tiene que
ser tanto detalle que viene cuando uno
lo crece desde desde el colín o desde
que tenemos las semillas del pp o
esto va a ser un problema serio en
cuanto podemos seguir elevando tratando
buscar un clima más templado digamos
pero el problema es que seguimos viendo
la tendencia de crecimiento en
temperaturas cuáles son las alternativas
que tenemos que tienen ustedes que
trabajan con el café para después paliar
esta crisis y que realmente no se acabe
porque yo creo que más de uno pues vamos
a morir dejamos sin el café
empezando por mí y por los sectores
clientes
es para mí todos los días tengo que
empezar el café el día sin con café si
no no empiezo el día
qué estamos haciendo pues ahí es donde
estamos en la ciencia digamos metidos
confiando en la gente que sabe los
agricultores de verdad que han estudiado
esto que están haciendo mutaciones o
están haciendo digamos crochet cruces
entre entre entre plantas en los
ochentas tuvimos el problema de la roya
y así pudimos salir de este problema
también con cruces digamos con una
planta mucho más resistente y la
pregunta es si empezamos a estas
variaciones y vamos a mantener la
calidad de café a la que nos estamos
acostumbrando el movimiento es a un café
mucho mejor a un café especial estamos
tomando un café de mucha mejor calidad y
no sabemos estos cruces con plantas de
pronto de menor calidad que tienen más
resistencia y que pueden hacer al perfil
de tazo pero por favor digamos una buena
noticia no se va a acabar el café no a
saber hacia dónde va el negocio cuál
sigue el futuro el café no el café por
ahora está sólido
de las de las cosas cambiadas de las más
cambiadas del mundo después del petróleo
de las bebidas más tomadas del mundo
después del agua y del té y el café por
ahora estamos bien y de verdad que todo
pienso que como como caficultor como
parte de esta industria somos muy
conscientes del cambio climático y
estamos estamos viendo qué movimientos
hacer para tener esto está proyectado el
2050 o sea por ahora tenemos que tenemos
café juegan ahora le quiero preguntar la
diferencia de los distintos granos de
café cuál es la diferencia por ejemplo
del café colombiano tan famoso en el
mundo además colombia el tercer
exportador a nivel mundial de este grano
cuál es la diferencia del café
colombiano con un café de brasil del de
vietnam o el de otros países la
diferencia de la variedad la diferencia
es el tipo de cultivo la diferencia es
el tipo de tierra la diferencia es la
forma de recolección la costumbre son
tantas diferencias pero en lo básico
tenemos diferentes diferentes variedades
de café
en brasil por ejemplo el mayor productor
casi una tercera parte tercera parte
como dije ellos crecen mucho robusta
robusta es un café que crece a mucho
menor elevación crece un grano mucho más
grande y mucho más rápido tenemos pp
mientras que aquí crecemos arábica
arábica crítica de variedad colombia
castilla que son variedades que resisten
la la
el cambio de clima y todas estas cosas
que estamos manejando de enfermedades
del café el tenemos variedades como
bourbon que viene de la isla bourbon
tenemos gays ya que se volvió tan famoso
de
panamá y ahoritica antier acabamos de
ganar campeón mundial de barismo en
milán con un café colombiano del valle
del cauca de la finca la inmaculada que
se llama negro eu genoy des que es un
padre al café que tomamos actualmente o
sea que esta cantidad variedad nos dan
un perfil de tasa bien increíble usted
como barista que recomienda a los
televidentes que diga bueno yo quiero ir
una tienda especializada de café y yo
quiero tomar un buen café que le
recomienda a los televidentes para
llegar y pues uno más o menos defenderse
como como si no supieran
exactamente
pienso que es importante no tanto puedo
recomendar porque todo va a ser pasado a
mi gusto lo cual es muy colombiano si yo
crecí en cali y mi finca digamos la
finca de mi abuelo era en el cauca
entonces yo soy muy parcial a ese perfil
de tasa sin embargo si ustedes no saben
que pedirles recomiendo ir a una tienda
o buscar siempre tienda de café especial
ya sabemos que un café especial es un
café que ha tenido
digamos ha sido medido ha sido captado
por los catadores cv y así ya sabemos
que tenemos un café de buena calidad de
ahí lo que yo recomiendo es empezar a
probar porque el café es como el vino a
ver qué te gusta si te gusta más amargo
más dulce citó más frutal menos frutal
más acá a carme lado eso es cuestión de
wang no quiero que se acaba la
entrevista sin preguntarle qué se
siguientes en parís está de tom cruise
pues al principio me daba como en que no
me lo creía
no lo comentaba mucho tampoco porque
pensaba que me quitaba de la
de lo que mi conocimiento de lo que
estudiado del del hecho de por qué de
pronto entonces piensa nada pero como
barista tom cruise es la anses que pero
darme cuenta que primero me cae súper
bien que me ha puesto a viajar por todo
el mundo que tenemos una relación súper
chévere
pero que él me sigue escogiendo a mí y
me sigue invitando a mí a que le haga
café o sea que algo estoy haciendo bien
y decidí fue voltearlo y decir que como
barista estoy haciendo algo pues juan
bueno yo le hago un invitación para que
por favor invita a probar un buen café
ya pues en estos días para ver qué tal
no los cafés que ustedes preparan
muchísimas gracias entonces por estar
aquí con nosotros en directo américa de
france antigua muchísimas gracias
estábamos hablando de conjugarse en tan
barista y empresario colombiano hablando
de el café y qué va a pasar con este
grano con esta crisis climática que
estamos viviendo además de cara a la con
26 que empieza este domingo en glasgow
en escocia